- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Today I'd like to
introduce you to the verb,
which is another part of speech.
But I suppose the most
fruitful place for us to begin
is by asking, "What is a verb?"
A verb is a part of
speech that has a bunch of
different functions, but one
of its most important functions
is that it can express or show action.
Verbs can show action.
In order to demonstrate
this, I have brought along
a little cartoon bear,
and I'm going to use this
bear in several sentences,
each of which will contain a verb.
Because all sentences contain verbs.
So I'm gonna write a couple
of sentences about the bear,
and every time I use a
verb, I'm gonna write it
in yellow like that.
Here we go.
The bear roars.
The bear runs.
The bear sleeps.
Now, each one of these
words in yellow is a verb.
Each one of them is an action,
and this is the first
thing that verbs can do.
Verbs can show action in sentences.
And, in fact, all sentences
must contain verbs.
You can learn anything.
David out.